Joe worked at this office where every now and then, the office manager would bring her nine-year-old to work. Good kid, kind of tomboyish.
乔曾在一家办公室工作，办公室经理偶尔会带她九岁的女儿来上班。那是个好孩子，有点像个假小子。
And she would just help out around the office. She would pass mail out. And over the time that I was there, she and I developed this kind of teasing relationship. She would come into my office, and she would drop my mail off and stick her tongue out at me. And I would fake chase her down the hallway or something.
她会帮着处理办公室里的杂事，比如分发邮件。在我待在那儿的那段时间里，我和她建立了一种互相打趣的关系。她会走进我的办公室，把信丢下，然后对我做鬼脸。而我会假装在走廊里追她，或者做点类似的互动。
That's sweet.
那真可爱。
Yeah, yeah. She was an incredibly sweet kid. And so there's this day when it's early in the morning. I've arrived at the office. And I go into the bathroom. And when I come out of the bathroom, I have my glasses in my shirt pocket, rather than on my head.
是啊，是啊。她是个非常甜的孩子。有一天一大早，我到了办公室，去了趟洗手间。出来时，我的眼镜放在衬衫口袋里，而不是戴在头上。
And I look down this hallway and I see this small person walking towards me. And I then get down and start to crab walk towards her. So I go down on my haunches and put my hands up as if they're claws and waddle towards her.
我看向走廊，看到一个矮小的人影正朝我走来。于是我蹲下身，开始像螃蟹一样朝她横着走。我压低身子，双手像爪子一样举起，摇摇晃晃地向她靠近。
And as I'm waddling towards her, I say, in this kind of creepy voice, "Oh, no, I can't believe you're here today." And then, at that moment, as I say "today," she comes into focus. And I realize, in fact, it's not at all the young girl who I thought it was. But it's in fact, one of our interns, a business intern who is a midget.
当我摇晃着走过去时，我用一种诡异的声音说：“噢，不，真不敢相信你今天在这儿。”就在那一刻，当我说到“今天”时，我看清了她的样子。我意识到，这根本不是我以为的那个小女孩，而是一位个子矮小的商务实习生。
And so she comes into focus. And I see her. And I'm horrified. And I go bolt upright. And I stand up, and I say, "Oh my god. I'm terribly sorry. I thought you were somebody else."
她进入了我的视野，我看到了她。我吓坏了，猛地站直身体，说：“天哪，真抱歉，我以为你是别人。”
And I think to myself, "Who could she possibly think that somebody else is?" And I wondered at the time, should I have tried to explain it to her? And it seems to me like one of those situations where it only gets worse the more you try to explain it. The only thing I could do was, in fact, apologize and then end all contact with her forever, right there.
我心想，她会觉得我是把谁错认成谁了？当时我在想，我是不是该试着跟她解释？但这看起来就像那种越解释越糟的情况。我唯一能做的，就是道歉，然后当场彻底断绝与她的所有联系，对吧？
Joe says the woman was utterly gracious. She introduces herself. She tries to put him at ease.
乔说那女士非常大度。她做了自我介绍，还试图让他放松下来。
But Joe says, not only did he cringe when this happened, he cringes every single time he tells this story. People cringe when they hear this story. And why? Seriously, why? What is it about certain stories that get this physical reaction out of us?
但乔说，这件事发生时他不仅感到尴尬，每次讲起这个故事时，他都还会感到尴尬。人们听到这个故事时也会感到尴尬。为什么？认真地问，为什么？究竟是什么让某些故事引发我们这种生理反应？
You know what I mean? What are the physical reactions we ever actually give a story? There's laughing. There's crying. There's cringing? It's in the top three?
你知道我的意思吗？我们对故事到底会有什么样的生理反应？有大笑，有流泪。尴尬算吗？它能在前三名里吗？
Well, this week on our radio show, This American Life, we have looked into this matter. And I have to say, if there is scientific literature specifically on the physiology or psychology of cringing, we and many helpful doctors and researchers were unable to find it. But from examining a wide array of cringe stories, we have made some tentative conclusions about what it is that makes us cringe.
好吧，本周在我们的广播节目《美国生活》中，我们探讨了这个问题。我不得不说，如果真的有关于尴尬的生理学或心理学的科学文献，我们和许多热心的医生及研究人员都没能找到。但通过研究各种各样的尴尬故事，我们对导致我们尴尬的原因得出了一些初步结论。
Consider please, Howie's story. It was his sixth grade graduation dance. There had been one teacher, Mrs. S, who had been really cruel to him all year long. He was chubby, and she used to examine his papers for food stains, which then she would hold up and show the entire class. She'd mock him in front of class up to the day of the graduation dance.
请看霍伊的故事。那是他六年级的毕业舞会。有一位老师，S老师，整整一年对他都非常刻薄。他很胖，她过去常检查他的作业纸上有没有食物污渍，然后拿起来展示给全班看。直到毕业舞会那天，她还在班上嘲笑他。
As we're in line, she's like, "OK, you're all going to high school. I want you to be good." And then she kind of stops. And she says, "Well, I don't know if we're all going to high school." She goes, "I don't know. What do you think, kids? You think Howard should pass?"
当我们排队时，她说：“好了，你们都要上高中了，我希望你们表现好一点。”然后她停顿了一下，说：“嗯，我不知道我们是不是都能上高中。”她说：“我不知道。你们怎么看，孩子们？你们觉得霍华德应该及格吗？”
And then all the sudden, my heart dropped into my stomach. "What do you mean, ma'am?" "Yeah, yeah, let him pass. Let him pass." "I don't know. I don't know if we should let Howard pass. It's up to you kids. It's up to you. Should Howard pass?" "Yes, yes." "Should he pass?" "Yes, yes." "I don't know."
突然间，我的心沉到了谷底。“您是什么意思，女士？”“是啊，让他及格吧，让他及格吧。”“我不知道。我不知道我们是否应该让霍华德及格。这取决于你们，孩子们。这取决于你们。霍华德应该及格吗？”“及格，及格。”“他应该及格吗？”“及格，及格。”“我不知道。”
That was humiliating, but that is not the part of the story that makes him cringe. The cringe part happens when, dressed in his best Saturday Night Fever tight pants and polyester shirt, he takes matters into his own hands. He takes action. At the end of the dance, relieved that he is, in fact, graduating, he finds her in the teachers' lounge.
那是种羞辱，但那并不是让他感到最尴尬的部分。尴尬的部分发生在他身穿最得意的《周末夜狂热》式紧身裤和涤纶衬衫，决定亲自出马的时候。他采取了行动。舞会结束时，得知自己确实要毕业了，他如释重负，并在教师休息室找到了她。
So I walk in. I'm feeling good. I'm smiling. I'm strutting around in my John Travolta clothes. I grab my jacket. And picture this really sweaty, fat little kid, clothes plastered to his body.
我走了进去，感觉很棒。我在微笑，穿着约翰·特拉沃尔塔风格的衣服大摇大摆地走着。我抓起外套。想象一下，一个汗流浃背、胖乎乎的小男孩，衣服贴在身上。
Mrs. S, who'd been so cruel, is standing with another Mrs. S, the French teacher.
那个曾经对他如此刻薄的S老师，正和另一位S老师——法语老师站在一起。
I basically bowed to the French teacher. And I said, "Enchantee, Madame S." And then I looked at the other Mrs. S., and I went, "Thank you so much, Mrs. S." And I took a deep bow. I actually waved my arm underneath my waist, bowing deep to my knees, you know, getting up, flipping my jacket with one finger over my shoulder and going a Jackson 5 spin around, and strutted out, thinking I was the coolest.
我基本上是向那位法语老师鞠了一躬，说：“Enchantee（幸会），S夫人。”然后看着另一位S夫人，我说：“非常感谢您，S夫人。”我深深地鞠了一躬。我实际上是在腰部挥动着手臂，深深地鞠到膝盖，你知道，起来的时候用一根手指甩动外套搭在肩上，来了一个杰克逊五人组式的旋转，然后大摇大摆地走出去，觉得自己酷毙了。
I remember that when I bowed, and I said "Enchantee," and all this, I remember their faces. And they were disgusted. There wasn't a smile. There wasn't some kind of, "Oh, thank you, Howard." It was basically silence, this stern, down-at-the-mouth like, uugh.
我记得当我鞠躬说“幸会”以及做那些动作时，我记得她们的表情。她们感到恶心。没有微笑，也没有那种“噢，谢谢你，霍华德”的客套。基本上是一片寂静，那种严厉的、撇着嘴的，呃。
The things that she did to him were just humiliating, he says. It was the fact that he decided to thank her for it. That's what makes him cringe.
他说，她对他所做的事情简直就是一种羞辱。让他感到尴尬的，是他竟然决定为此感谢她。
And that seems to be true of a lot of cringe stories. The people in them go out of their way to embarrass themselves. In Joe's case, to get back to the guy crab walking in the office, if he had just come out of the men's room with his fly open, for example, that would've been embarrassing.
这似乎适用于很多尴尬故事。故事中的人总是费尽心思去让自己出丑。就乔的例子而言，回到办公室里那个横着走的人，如果他只是拉链没拉从男厕所出来，那会很尴尬。
But he went further. He made a special effort. A part of him was proud that he was the one adult in the office cool enough to goof around with a little kid. And pride, my friend, goeth before a cringe.
但他做得更过分。他格外卖力。他内心深处的一部分为自己是办公室里唯一一个能和小孩打闹、足够酷的大人而感到自豪。朋友，骄傲之后必有尴尬。
You know, you're in your office. And then suddenly, you're just like, "You know, I'm in a pretty good mood today. And I'm ready to goof around a little. I'm going to crouch down by these mailboxes, and I'm going to walk like a crab towards her down the hallway. This is a stuffy place full of stuffy people, and I'm still a pretty fun guy."
你知道，你在办公室里，突然间你觉得：“你知道吗，我今天心情很好，想闹一闹。我要在这些信箱旁蹲下，然后像螃蟹一样沿着走廊向她走去。这地方闷死人了，全是闷蛋，但我还是个挺有趣的人。”
You cringe in that moment of revelation, when you suddenly see that maybe you are not the fun guy, when you see yourself as others see you. And it is not pretty. One of the doctors that we talked to about cringes for this week's show pointed out that a cringe is basically the human body cowering in fear for an instant. And he said that one of the most fearsome, stressful things that we can encounter as people is the thought that we are not who we think we are, the thought that the world sees us differently than we see ourselves, and not in a good way.
你在那种顿悟的时刻会感到尴尬，当你突然发现自己也许并不是那个有趣的人时，当你像别人看你那样审视自己时。那感觉并不美妙。我们为本周节目采访的一位医生指出，尴尬本质上是人体在恐惧中瞬间畏缩的反应。他说，作为人，我们能遇到的最可怕、压力最大的事情之一，就是想到我们并不是自己以为的那样，想到世界看待我们的眼光与我们看待自己的不同，而且不是好的那一面。
Well, our program today, as always from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. Today on our show, an investigation into stories that make us cringe. Act One, What We Cringe About When We Cringe About Love. Nancy Updike explains the peculiar characteristics of a cringe love affair. Act Two, M*A*S*H Notes, in which I tell a story from my past that I actually spent two decades trying to forget about a week that I had back in 1979 on the set of a television show. Also in that story, why I hope to never run into Alan Alda on the street.
好的，我们的节目一如既往来自芝加哥WBEZ，由国际公共广播电台发行。今天节目中，我们将调查那些让我们感到尴尬的故事。第一幕：当我们为爱感到尴尬时，我们到底在尴尬什么？南希·厄普代克将解释尴尬恋情的独特特征。第二幕：M*A*S*H便条，我会讲述一段我花了二十年试图忘记的往事，关于1979年我在一部电视剧片场度过的一周。在那段故事里，我还将提到为什么我希望永远不要在街上碰到艾伦·阿尔达。
Act Three, Ariel Sharon, Shimon Peres, David Ben-Gurion and Me, the story of one teenager's cringeworthy dream, to become prime minister of a nation in which he does not even reside. Act Four, Cringe and Purge. We have a story from Bruce Jay Friedman about a man who tries to rid himself of a decades-old cringe, if that is really possible. Stay with us.
第三幕：阿里埃勒·沙龙、西蒙·佩雷斯、戴维·本-古里安和我，讲述了一个十几岁少年的尴尬梦想——成为一个他甚至不住在其中的国家的总理。第四幕：尴尬与净化。我们有一篇来自布鲁斯·杰伊·弗里德曼的故事，讲述了一个男人如何试图摆脱长达数十年的尴尬，如果这真的可能的话。请继续收听。
Act One, What We Cringe About When We Cringe About Love. If cringing is basically shrinking from something dangerous or painful, what could be more potentially dangerous and painful than love? Nancy Updike has this report on the characteristics and bylaws of cringe love.
第一幕：当我们为爱感到尴尬时，我们到底在尴尬什么？如果尴尬本质上是对危险或痛苦事物的退缩，那么还有什么比爱更具有潜在的危险和痛苦呢？南希·厄普代克带来了关于尴尬恋情的特征和法则的报道。
A cringe love story always starts with a one-liner.
尴尬的爱情故事总是从一句开场白开始。
went out with a guy whose role models were Jean Genet and Clint Eastwood.
我曾和一个以让·热内和克林特·伊斯特伍德为榜样的家伙约会。
I once went out with this alcoholic. And I guess I just didn't realize he was an alcoholic, because he was doing so much cocaine at the time.
我曾和一个酒鬼约会过。我想我当时没意识到他是酒鬼，因为他那时吸了太多的可卡因。
I once dated a guy who, three months after we broke up, slept with both his stepmother and his stepsister.
我曾经和一个男人约会，他在我们分手三个月后，和他继母及继姐都睡了。
You probably notice these are all women. That's because cringe love stories are usually embarrassing. And I'm generalizing here, but in my experience, women like telling embarrassing love stories. We bond over them. We like to one-up each other. "You did that for love? Well, I did this."
你可能注意到了这些全是女性。这是因为尴尬的爱情故事通常都很丢脸。我在这里概括一下，但在我的经验中，女性喜欢讲述丢脸的爱情故事。我们通过这些故事建立联系。我们喜欢彼此攀比。“你为了爱做了那种事？好吧，那我做了这个。”
And while I'm generalizing, let me also say that as far as I can tell, the most common cringe love story is the kind that takes place in your early 20s with a guy not that much older. And you are new at love. It's not your first relationship.
在概括的同时，我也想说，据我所知，最常见的尴尬爱情故事是发生在二十岁出头时，对方年纪没大多少。那时你对爱情还很陌生。这虽然不是你的第一段恋情。
But everything about your romantic self still feels on loan from somewhere else-- movies, rumors, your friends. You don't quite know who you are yet when it comes to love because you're still becoming that person. And everything these early 20s cringe love stories have to teach us, we can learn from a woman from Texas named Julie.
但你关于浪漫自我的一切感觉，似乎都是从别处借来的——电影、传闻、你的朋友。当谈到爱情时，你还不太了解自己，因为你还在变成那个人。所有这些二十岁出头时尴尬的爱情故事想要教给我们的，我们都可以从一位名叫朱莉的德克萨斯州女性身上学到。
I once went out with a guy who, while we were dating, joined the Hare Krishnas.
我曾和一个在我们约会期间加入克里希纳知觉运动的男人交往。
So how did he tell you this?
那么他是怎么告诉你的？
Well, we started going to Prasadam, which is this thing the Krishnas do on Sundays. They have this big feast. And basically, it was a way to get free food.
嗯，我们开始去吃Prasadam，那是克里希纳教徒在周日做的事情。他们有大聚餐。基本上，这是一种获取免费食物的方式。
Free food is very important in this story. The reason is that Julie's boyfriend was a squatter. Do you know what that is? For years, in cities all over the country, people have been taking over abandoned buildings and living in them, squatting. People do it for a lot of reasons, anti-corporate idealism, adventure, lack of interest in getting a job.
免费食物在这个故事中非常重要。原因在于朱莉的男友是个擅自占用空房者。你知道那是什么吗？多年来，在全国各地的城市里，人们一直占据废弃建筑并在其中生活，这就是擅自占用空房。人们这样做有很多原因，反企业的理想主义、冒险，或者不想找工作。
Julie's boyfriend was a middle-class kid from New York who, when they met, was squatting in an abandoned warehouse in Austin, Texas, bartering, hitchhiking, and keeping an eye out for free food. Julie, at the time, lived in an air-conditioned apartment and drove an Oldsmobile. She was in her last year of college.
朱莉的男友是个来自纽约的中产阶级孩子，他们相遇时，他正住在奥斯汀一个废弃的仓库里，靠以物易物、搭车旅行，并留意免费食物。朱莉当时住在有空调的公寓里，开着一辆奥兹莫比尔。她正读大学最后一年。
We used to go around whenever I wanted pizza. We couldn't order pizza. We had to go to all the pizza places and ask for mistakes, because he didn't believe in paying for anything. And he used to say that when we did that, that I couldn't go in because I looked too much like a sorority girl, which I'm not. But he said I looked like one.
每当我想吃披萨时，我们就会到处转悠。我们不能点披萨。我们必须去所有的披萨店问有没有做错的，因为他不相信付钱买任何东西。他常说，当我们那样做时，我不能进去，因为我看起来太像个联谊会女孩了，虽然我不是。但他坚持说我看起来像。
So squatter guy meets college girl. A princess, he'd call her. And they fall in love during an AIDS outreach workshop.
于是，擅自占用空房的家伙遇到了大学生女孩。他叫她公主。他们在一次艾滋病外展研讨会上坠入爱河。
A lot of cringe love stories take this form, living on the edge guy meets suburban girl. They move in together to her bourgeois apartment. He takes her on midnight bike rides. She buys him dinner in real restaurants. He spare-changes on the corner to take them out for ice cream. And every week, they go to Prasadam to get a free vegetarian meal from the Hare Krishnas.
许多尴尬的爱情故事都是这种形式：生活在边缘的家伙遇到了郊区女孩。他们搬进她的小资公寓里住。他带她深夜骑行。她请他在真正的餐馆吃晚餐。他在街角讨零钱带他们去吃冰激凌。每周，他们都去吃Prasadam，从克里希纳教徒那里领取免费的素食餐。
And then one day, he came home after Prasadam. And he said he thought he'd like to go to classes in the morning. They had classes where you could learn more about Krishna consciousness. And I said that that was cool. I wasn't really interested in it. So he started going to classes. That's how it started.
有一天，他从Prasadam回来。他说他想去上早课。他们有可以了解更多关于克里希纳知觉的课程。我说那很好。我对那个不太感兴趣。于是他开始去上课。事情就是这样开始的。
Then he came home, and he wanted me to shave his head, which wan't that big of a deal. I thought it was actually kind of cute. But then he came home and he had the gear.
然后他回家了，想让我帮他剃头，这其实没啥大不了。我觉得这其实还挺可爱的。但后来他带回了装备。
He had this long, white sheath they call a dhoti. And he told me he was going to start wearing that. And that's when I started feeling kind of weird about it.
他有一条长长的白色衬裙，他们叫它Dhoti。他告诉我他要开始穿那个了。也就是在那时，我开始对此感到有点怪异。
We started fighting because he had this new belief system. He'd become totally vegan. So we couldn't go to our favorite restaurants because, well, not only was it that he was vegan, but he couldn't go to a place where he didn't know what the the emotions of the cook were. Like if they were angry, that would get into the food. These were all things he'd picked up in Krishna consciousness.
我们开始吵架，因为他有了这种新的信仰体系。他完全变成了素食主义者。所以我们不能再去我们最喜欢的餐馆了，因为，不仅因为他是素食主义者，他还不能去那种他不知道厨师情绪的地方。就像如果他们生气了，那会进入食物中。这些都是他在克里希纳知觉中学到的东西。
Every relationship that doesn't work out has some problem that can't be solved. With cringe love, it's an embarrassing problem. And looking back, it's not just the problem that makes you cringe. It's how long the relationship continued after this problem could not have been more clear, not only to you, but also to all your friends. That is, if you weren't hiding it from them.
每一段无法维持的恋情都有一些无法解决的问题。对于尴尬的爱情来说，这是一个令人难堪的问题。回首往事，让你感到尴尬的不仅仅是问题本身。而是当这个问题已经再明显不过时，这段关系还持续了那么久，不仅是对你，对你所有的朋友也是如此。前提是你没向他们隐瞒的话。
And all of this was a secret from all of my friends. I didn't tell any of them anything. But one day I came home, and I had a friend over. And John was there.
所有这一切都是我朋友们的秘密。我没告诉她们中的任何一个。但有一天我回家时，有个朋友在。约翰也在。
And I walked in, and my whole living room smelled of incense. And he'd turned my bookshelf into a shrine to Swami Prabhupada. There was this big picture. There was candles. There was scarves.
我走进门，整个客厅闻起来都是熏香的味道。他把我的书架变成了一个斯瓦米·帕布帕德的祭坛。有一张大照片。还有蜡烛。还有围巾。
And I said, "Honey, who's that?" And he said, "That's Swami Prabhupada." And I'm like, OK. And he said, "Do you want me to take him down?" and gets defensive right away. And I'm like, "No, that's cool. I was just wondering who there is a shrine to in my living room."
我说：“亲爱的，那是谁？”他说：“那是斯瓦米·帕布帕德。”我说，好吧。他说：“你想让我把它取下来吗？”立刻变得防备起来。我说：“不，这很好。我只是好奇在我的客厅里给谁立了个祭坛。”
So then later, my friend left. And we just had this huge, huge fight. And it started because he had these beads. And he'd gotten me these beads.
后来，我朋友走了。我们大吵了一架。起因是他有那些珠子。他给我弄了那些珠子。
And the Krishnas have these-- kind of like a rosary. But it's about 20 beads, and you're supposed to repeat this mantra. It's out of Hair. "Hare Krishna, Hare Krishna, Krishna, Krishna, Hare, Hare."
克里希纳教徒有这些——有点像念珠。但大约有20颗珠子，你要重复这个咒语。出自《毛发》音乐剧。“Hare Krishna, Hare Krishna, Krishna, Krishna, Hare, Hare。”
You're supposed to repeat it 20 times. So you do it 400 times a day. So he's decided that if I do this, that I'll be happy, that all this anger I'm having is because I'm not chanting Hare Krishna and being happy.
你要重复20遍。所以你每天要做400次。他认定如果我这样做，我就会快乐，认定我所有的愤怒都是因为我没有念诵哈瑞·克里希纳并感到快乐。
So I take these beads. And I'm like, "I'm not going to do this." And he said, "Why not? Why won't you worship Krishna?"
所以我拿起这些珠子，说：“我才不做这个。”他说：“为什么不？你为什么不崇拜克里希纳？”
This is the moment every cringe relationship comes down to in the end, the point where one person turns to the other and asks a question like--
这就是每一段尴尬关系最终归结的时刻，一方转向另一方问出这样的问题——
"Why not? Why won't you worship Krishna?"
“为什么不？你为什么不崇拜克里希纳？”
That's because at the heart of the cringe is a fundamental disagreement in the way you see the world. He's Montague. You're Capulet. He's 60 Minutes. You're Felicity. He's potato. You're po-tah-to, but you just can't call the whole thing off. Because on paper, the relationship seemed so romantic. The very things that make you cringe looking back, at the time were just challenges on the path to love, and not just any love, the best kind-- impossible love.
这是因为尴尬的核心在于你们看待世界的方式存在根本分歧。他是蒙太古，你是凯普莱特。他是《60分钟》，你是《费莉希蒂》。他是土豆，你是（另一种发音的）土豆，但你们就是无法结束这一切。因为在纸面上，这段关系看起来如此浪漫。回想起来，正是那些让你感到尴尬的事情，在当时只是通往爱情之路上的挑战，而且不仅仅是任何爱情，是最好的那种——不可能的爱。
There was a point where I wanted to go to law school. And we were talking about moving to San Francisco. And I would go to Boalt, and he would hang out at the airport.
曾有一段时间我想去法学院。我们在谈论搬到旧金山。我会去伯克利法学院（Boalt），他会在机场闲逛。
Wait a minute, you would go where, and he would go to the airport?
等一下，你会去哪儿，而他会去机场？
Boalt, the law school at Berkeley is called Boalt.
Boalt，伯克利法学院被称为Boalt。
Oh, OK. And he would go to the airport. I don't understand.
噢，好吧。而他会去机场。我不明白。
The Krishnas hang out at the airport.
克里希纳教徒常在机场闲逛。
Right.
没错。
Julie laughs when she tells this now. She knows this story is one of the funniest things that's ever happened to her, and she loves telling it. She savors every absurdity in the story, and every absurd turn within every absurdity. But when I talked to her a few days after our interview, she said, "You know, it's the weirdest thing. After we talked that night, I went home and cried."
朱莉现在讲这个故事时会笑。她知道这是她发生过的最有趣的事情之一，她喜欢讲述它。她细细品味故事中的每一个荒谬之处，以及每一个荒谬中的每一个荒谬转折。但在我们采访几天后我与她交谈时，她说：“你知道，这事最奇怪了。那天晚上我们谈过之后，我回到家哭了。”
For Julie, this relationship was the first time she fell in love. John was different from anyone else she'd ever known. When she had to go out of town the first week after they met, she thought about him every minute.
对朱莉来说，这段恋情是她第一次坠入爱河。约翰与她曾经认识的任何人都不同。当他们在见面后的第一周她必须出城时，她每一分钟都在想他。
And when I got back, he'd sent me cards from every place in Austin, with my name in them, or with a poem about me in them. He just pursued me. And he was just really romantic and exciting. Like, we did not go out for movie and a dinner ever, I think, the whole time we dated. Not that that's not nice-- that's great and everything.
当我回来时，他从奥斯汀的每个地方都给我寄了卡片，上面写着我的名字，或者写着关于我的诗。他一直在追求我。他真的非常浪漫和令人兴奋。我觉得我们整个约会期间，甚至从来没出去看过电影或吃过晚餐。倒不是说那不美好——那当然很棒，诸如此类的。
But I remember, he wrote me this card from when he went on the hitchhiking trip. And he took a picture of me with him. And the postcard said, "Hey, cheesecake, thanks for the cheesecake pic." He said, "I show it around to the other guys on the--" he was actually train-hopping at that point, "--on the train." And he says, "It solicits envious grunts of approval. But no one says anything boring, like 'she's beautiful.'" And I just thought, who would write love letters like this?
但我记得，他从搭车旅行时给我写了这张卡片。他带了一张我和他的照片。明信片上写着：“嘿，芝士蛋糕，谢谢那张芝士蛋糕照片。”他说：“我给其他人看过了……”他当时实际上是在扒火车，——“在火车上。”他说：“这引发了羡慕的咕哝声。但没人说些无聊的话，比如‘她很漂亮’。”我当时就想，谁会写这样的情书？
She's reciting these lines from the postcard from memory. It's the only love letter she's kept as she's moved from place to place. But then, that's part of it. Her love for him is part of what she's cringing about when she looks back.
她凭记忆背诵了明信片上的这些话。这是她在搬家过程中一直保留的唯一一封情书。但话说回来，这也是其中的一部分。她对他的爱，正是她回首往事时感到尴尬的一部分。
What's the part of the story where you cringe most and just think, "Ugh, why did I do that?"
故事中你感到最尴尬、只觉得“呃，我为什么会那样做”的部分是什么？
I think it was when I ironed the dhoti.
我想是我熨那件Dhoti的时候。
Remember the dhoti? That's that long, white sheath Julie's boyfriend had started wearing. He asked her one day to iron it.
还记得那件Dhoti吗？那是朱莉男友开始穿的那条长长的白色衬裙。有一天他让她熨一下。
It was 25 feet long. and I ironed the whole thing.
它有25英尺长。我把整条都熨了。
So you did iron it.
所以你确实熨了它。
I ironed the dhoti.
我熨了那条Dhoti。
And what did you say to yourself about why you were ironing it?
那你对自己说为什么要熨它？
I'm in love? I don't know. What do you say when you do stupid sh--? I wanted him to look nice for temple. I didn't want him to be the bad-looking bhakta with the uncool girlfriend.
因为我恋爱了？我不知道。当你做蠢事时你会怎么说？我想让他去神庙时看起来不错。我不想让他成为那个穿着难看的Bhakta，带着一个不懂行的女朋友。
Not wanting to be uncool motivates a surprising number of cringe love stories. I had long talks about cringe love with a few women besides Julie, one of whom once found herself working two jobs to support a boyfriend who spent all day writing in his journal about the affair he was having with someone else.
不想显得“不懂行”促成了令人惊讶数量的尴尬爱情故事。除了朱莉，我还和几位女性长谈过尴尬的爱情，其中一位发现自己同时打两份工，供养一个整天在日记里写着他与另一个女人私情的男朋友。
What makes you cringe is not so much that you are in a relationship that now seems ridiculous. It's that you wanted that ridiculous relationship. You got on the train. It was romantic. You were right in there. And you know it could happen again at any time. Who isn't willing to be ridiculous for love?
让你尴尬的不是因为你处在一段现在看起来荒谬的关系中。而是你曾经想要那段荒谬的关系。你上了那辆火车。它很浪漫。你完全投入其中。而且你知道它随时可能再次发生。谁不愿为爱变得荒唐呢？
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "WHEN YOU WERE MINE" BY CYNDI LAUPER]
[音乐播放 - 辛迪·劳帕的《WHEN YOU WERE MINE》]
Act Two: M*A*S*H Notes. At one point during the height of the Monica Lewinsky scandal, Bill Clinton said this to the press about the ongoing investigations, rumors, and accusations.
第二幕：M*A*S*H便条。在莫妮卡·莱温斯基丑闻最严重的时期，比尔·克林顿曾这样对媒体谈论正在进行的调查、谣言和指控。
I just have to try to put this in a little box, like I have every other thing that has been said and done and go on and do my job. That's what I'm going to work at.
我只是试图把这一切放在一个小盒子里，就像我处理过去说过和做过的每一件事一样，继续做我的工作。这就是我要努力的方向。
I think once we get to a certain age, so many things have happened in our lives that make us cringe, that it is no longer a box. It's like a whole room full of boxes, any one of which makes us cringe. And what we do is we try to keep the door to that room closed.
我想一旦我们到了某个年纪，生活中发生的太多事情都会让我们感到尴尬，以至于这不再是一个盒子了。这就像一个装满盒子的房间，随便拿出一个都能让我们尴尬。我们所做的就是试着关上那个房间的门。
But the fact is there are so many ways into those rooms. There's so many things that can remind us of the things that we feel ashamed of. For me, six months doesn't pass with at least one nightmare involving the cast and crew of the TV show M*A*S*H.
但事实是，进入那些房间的方法有很多。有很多事情会提醒我们那些感到羞耻的事。对我来说，每隔六个月，至少会有一次噩梦涉及到电视剧《M*A*S*H》的演职人员。
Quiet, please. Roll camera.
安静一下。开始拍摄。
Don't you think it's about time it became an Army matter?
你不觉得是时候让它成为军队事务了吗？
When I was 20, back in 1979, I spent four days on the set of M*A*S*H. I'd written them this letter on National Public Radio stationery, asking if I could do a story about the show. I watched them film scenes and rehearse lines.
1979年我20岁时，在《M*A*S*H》片场待了四天。我用美国国家公共广播电台的信纸给他们写了封信，询问是否可以做一个关于该节目的故事。我看着他们拍摄场景，排练台词。
Could be a good idea, Hawkeye could be an accessory before the fight.
也许是个好主意，鹰眼可能会成为斗殴前的从犯。
That could be very useful, Hawkeye.
那会非常有用，鹰眼。
Oh, you say that? You say that?
噢，你是这样说的？你是这样说的？
That could be very useful, Hawkeye.
那会非常有用，鹰眼。
Could be useful, he says.
他说，可能会有用。
Well, well, I say. Well, OK. We'll let-- let's-- we'll let-- OK, well, OK, we'll let balder heads prevail. What?
嗯，好吧，我说。嗯，好吧。我们要让——我们要让——嗯，好吧，我们让更冷静的头脑占据主导。什么？
I'd been an intern at NPR. I'd had short-term jobs on specials and documentaries and on All Things Considered, which meant that I was pretty much skillful enough to get access to official stationery, but not actually skilled enough to know how to do a real story on my own. Recently, I listened to the cassettes of these old interviews for the first time in 20 years, and it was one long cringe-a-thon.
我当时是NPR的实习生。我在特辑和纪录片以及《All Things Considered》节目做过短期工作，这意味着我技能足够拿到官方信纸，但实际上并没有能力自己完成一个真正的故事。最近，我二十年来第一次听了这些旧采访的磁带，这是一场漫长的尴尬马拉松。
I ask lots of very strange questions on the tapes, questions that usually begin this way. There's the rumbling noise of somebody mishandling a microphone, and then a little rambling preamble before the actual question.
我在磁带里问了很多非常奇怪的问题，这些问题通常以这种方式开始。有某人笨拙处理麦克风的隆隆声，然后是实际问题前的一段冗长的序言。
One thing that's-- one of the messages-- one of the messages that I always get from the show is that every person should be listened to. Every person should be-- it's a very humanitarian, almost a populist sort of message that every person deserves some attention. But is there a problem with that with you? Because if you give everybody who knows you, now, by seeing you on TV, some attention, isn't that difficult? I mean, can't there be just a lot of pressure with that?
有一件事是——其中一个信息——我从这个节目中总是得到的信息是，每个人都应该被倾听。每个人都应该——这是一个非常人道主义、近乎民粹主义的信息，每个人都值得关注。但这对你来说是个问题吗？因为如果你给每一个现在通过电视看到你而认识你的人一些关注，那不是很难吗？我的意思是，那不会有很大压力吗？
The answer to that long question is yes, of course.
那个冗长问题的答案当然是肯定的。
This is the actor who played Klinger on the series. He is unfailingly gracious. In fact, everybody is unfailingly gracious, the stars, the extras, the writers, the crew. In a certain sense, that just makes it worse. It's one thing to be an ass in front of people who are also acting like asses. It is another to hear that you are the one and only idiot in the room.
这位是剧中扮演克林格的演员。他始终如一地客气。事实上，每个人都始终如一地客气，明星们、临时演员们、编剧们、工作人员们。从某种意义上说，这让情况更糟了。在同样表现得像蠢货的人面前做一个蠢货是一回事。而在房间里成为唯一一个白痴，感觉又是另一回事。
At the time, I didn't really know how exactly to prepare for this kind of story. And in retrospect, I have to say, I probably should have watched the program a little more intensively before going to California. Intensively enough, for example, to correctly pronounce all the characters' names.
当时，我真的不知道该如何为这种故事做准备。回想起来，我不得不说，去加州之前，我可能应该更深入地观看那个节目。深入到足以，例如，正确地读出所有角色的名字。
OK. Well, where should I start? Of all the characters, Father Mulcagy seems to have remained the most constant over the years.
好吧，我该从哪儿开始？在所有角色中，穆尔卡吉神父似乎多年来一直是最稳定的一个。
How are you pronouncing my name? Father? I have to hear you pronounce it to make sure you pronounce it right.
你是怎么读我的名字的？神父？我得听你读一遍，确保你读对了。
Mulcahy?
穆尔卡吉（Mulcahy）？
Oh, that's good. Good, good. No, that's fine.
噢，那很好。好，好。不，没关系。
Well, most people don't see it spelled.
嗯，大多数人没见过它的拼写。
Well, no, I think that the spelling bothers people, because of the H close to the end.
嗯，不，我认为拼写困扰着人们，因为结尾附近的那个H。
You see now, until I came here and saw a script, I didn't know that. And I always assumed that it was Mulcagy.
你看现在，直到我来到这里看到剧本，我才知道这一点。我一直以为是Mulcagy。
That's what I thought you might have said. It sounded sort of like you said that. Believe me, Ira--
我猜你可能就是那样说的。听起来像是你说的那样。相信我，艾拉——
At some point in my brief time working at NPR I'd been told that one way to put people at ease in an interview is to talk a little bit about yourself. If you tell a personal story, they tell a personal story. It's just human nature, I was told. So the seven hours of tape are filled with one little story after another that I tell about my life, trying to relate and all.
在我NPR短暂的工作期间，曾有人告诉我，采访时让人们放松的一种方法是多谈谈自己。如果你讲一个个人故事，他们也会讲一个个人故事。我被告知，这只是人性。所以那七小时的录音里，充满了我在讲述自己生活的一段又一段小故事，试图与之建立联系。
One thing that happens in radio production, I know, is-- let me think of an example. Sometimes we'll be producing something. And we had a Halloween special. And we had a genetic engineer.
我知道，广播制作中发生的一件事是——让我想想例子。有时我们会制作一些节目。我们有一个万圣节特辑。我们请了一位基因工程师。
One thing that I'm just thinking of as you're saying this is when I'm-- I mean, I've written a lot of scripts for commercials and for plays at schools and things like that. And there's so many times that I'm not in a scene. But I give them the dialogue.
当你这么说的时候，我想起的一件事是——我的意思是，我为商业广告、学校戏剧等写过很多剧本。有很多次我不在场景中。但我给他们台词。
And I'll sit there. And they'll say it. And I'll say, "No, it doesn't sound right. I'll fix it," just to deal with the actor. And then they'll do it. And I'll think to myself, ah, I could do it better. Do you ever--
我就坐在那儿。他们说出来。我会说，“不，听起来不对。我来修一下，”只是为了应付演员。然后他们会照做。我会对自己想，啊，我能做得更好。你有过——
How much-- when I think of myself doing any sort of radio show, I feel like I'm trying to-- I feel like I've got this audience, and I've got these people. And I want to talk to them, you know? I want to get myself across.
多少——当我想到自己做任何广播节目时，我感觉我在努力——我觉得我拥有这个听众群，我拥有这些人。我想和他们对话，你知道吗？我想传达我自己。
I'm a college sophomore, literally. What's striking about these questions is that they combine complete naivete with condescension. I am both clueless, and I think I know it all.
我简直是个大二学生。这些问题的惊人之处在于它们结合了彻底的天真与屈尊俯就。我既是个没头苍蝇，又自以为无所不知。
Listening now, it's not the utter presumptuousness of it all that gets to me. It's the awkward moments where I hear myself just saying anything that I can think of, clumsy jokes and stories that are half-true and this kind of fake, familiar joshing, and basically anything else trying to make a connection. I cringe more at that because that is absolutely still in me. I hear that still in the interviews that I do now for this radio show. And most of the time we try to cut that out. What we cringe most at are the things we hate most in ourselves.
现在听起来，让我难受的不是那种彻底的自以为是。而是那些尴尬的时刻，我听到自己胡乱说着任何能想到的东西，笨拙的笑话，半真半假的故事，还有那种虚假的、装熟的戏谑，以及基本上任何试图建立联系的做法。我对此感到更加尴尬，因为那绝对仍然存在于我身上。我在我现在为这个广播节目做的采访中依然能听到那些。大多数时候我们试图把它们剪掉。我们最尴尬的是我们身上最讨厌的部分。
Also horrifying on these tapes are questions whose sheer rudeness I was simply too young and ignorant to understand. Asking some of the extras, do they ever want, you know, speaking parts. Asking one of the show's stars if he really doesn't think to himself sometimes, "Is this TV stuff really as worthwhile as Shakespeare?" Asking Harry Morgan, the great character actor who played Colonel Potter on the show, and who had been on countless TV shows since the beginning of the medium, this question.
录音带上同样令人惊恐的，还有一些我太年轻、太无知而无法理解的纯粹粗鲁的问题。问一些临时演员他们是否想要台词角色。问该剧的明星之一他是否真的不觉得自己有时在想，“这电视玩意儿真的像莎士比亚那样有价值吗？”问哈里·摩根，那位在剧中扮演波特上校的伟大性格演员，他自该媒介诞生以来出演过无数电视节目，问他这个问题。
It seems like in most of your roles, you're always there, but you're never the lead. You're never the center. Why is that?
似乎在你的大多数角色中，你总是出现，但从来不是主角。你从来不是中心。为什么？
Well, I don't know. Some people just sort of fall into that category. I think all my life I've been a supporting character.
嗯，我不知道。有些人只是落入了那个类别。我想我这辈子一直是个配角。
It didn't occur to the 20-year-old me what it might mean to spend decades as an actor, doing fine, but not being offered leading man parts. Oblivious, I pressed on.
20岁的我没想过作为一个演员，表现不错却没被提供男主角的角色意味着什么。我一无所知，继续追问。
You must get the offers. You must-- you've been around.
你肯定收到过邀约。你肯定——你一直在圈子里。
No, nobody's offered me the lead in a show.
不，没人给我提供节目的主角。
At that point, even I figure it out.
在那一点上，连我自己都反应过来了。
What makes a-- I'm changing the subject. What makes a successful television show?
什么造就了——我在转移话题。什么造就了一个成功的电视节目？
Again, he is unfailingly gracious. Since then, I've flipped past Harry Morgan's face in old episodes of Dragnet. He shows up sometimes in old black and white movies. He's actually in a lot of classics, like Inherit the Wind and High Noon. And every time I'm watching something, and he appears, I wince. It's hard to watch. Sometimes, out of the blue, I just remember the fact of his existence, and I cringe.
他再次客气得不得了。此后，我在《Dragnet》的旧剧集中翻过哈里·摩根的脸。他有时会出现在老黑白电影里。他实际上出演了许多经典作品，如《Inherit the Wind》和《High Noon》。每次我在看什么东西，他出现时，我都会退缩。这很难看下去。有时，我会毫无预兆地想起他存在的事实，然后感到尴尬。
Out of all this tape, though, my most cringeworthy line of questions had to do with what I called then the "message" or the "morals" of the show. The 20-year-old me seems to have been fixated on this idea that TV and radio should impart big, important ideas to the people all the time. Though, weirdly, whenever I bring this up on the tapes, I seem somehow to lack the language to express this thought clearly. Here's how I begin my interview with Alan Alda, who won Emmys on M*A*S*H for acting and for writing and for directing.
不过，在所有这些录音带中，我最令人尴尬的一系列问题与我当时所说的节目的“信息”或“道德”有关。20岁的我似乎总是执着于这样一种想法：电视和广播应该时刻向人们灌输重大的、重要的思想。虽然奇怪的是，每当我在录音中提起这点时，我似乎总是缺乏表达这种思想的语言。以下是我采访艾伦·阿尔达的开始，他在《M*A*S*H》中获得了表演、写作和导演的艾美奖。
All your recent writing and directing and acting are-- all the stories have a very-- they show a lot of human values, very moralistic in a lot of ways. Do you believe that television and film should teach?
你最近所有的写作、导演和表演都——所有的故事都有一个非常——它们展现了很多人的价值观，在很多方面非常道德化。你是否认为电视和电影应该传道？
I think that to answer that question, I'd have to know what you mean by moralistic. That sounds faintly pejorative to me. I don't know. Tell me a little bit more about what you mean.
我认为要回答这个问题，我得知道你所谓的道德化是什么意思。那对我来说听起来有点贬义。我不知道。再多告诉我一点你的意思。
Well, when you-- what are you trying to-- well, maybe you should define it for me. What are you trying to tell your audience?
嗯，当你——你想要什么——好吧，也许你应该为我定义一下。你试图告诉观众什么？
OK, I think that for me, the kind of writing that appeals to me the most, and the kind of writing that I try to accomplish, is the kind that--
好吧，我认为对我来说，最吸引我的写作风格，以及我试图实现的写作风格，是那种——
For 45 minutes on the tape, I ask Alan Alda question after question. I quote him egghead ideas from egghead books. And miraculously, he gives kind of a great interview, mostly by ignoring my actual words and trying to respond to what it is that I seem to be interested in.
在录音带上，我问了艾伦·阿尔达一个接一个的问题，整整45分钟。我引用书呆子书籍中的书呆子思想。奇迹般的是，他做了一次非常棒的采访，主要是通过忽略我实际的词句，试着回应我似乎感兴趣的东西。
It turns out, he's not interested in teaching anybody a lesson, a political lesson, a moral lesson. He hates that idea. His goal is much simpler. He's interested in stories that just capture the way people are.
事实证明，他没兴趣给任何人上一课，无论是政治课还是道德课。他讨厌那种想法。他的目标简单得多。他感兴趣的是那些能捕捉人们生活状态的故事。
And I don't want to sound self-congratulatory. There are times that I don't think we make it, plenty of times. There are things I see sometimes that I wince at.
我不想听起来自命不凡。有几次我觉得我们没成功，次数很多。有时我看到一些东西，我会感到退缩。
But we're always trying, that I will give us credit for, to reflect real experience. And the audience hasn't rejected us for that. In fact, the more we've been able to do that, the more the audience has made us popular.
但我们一直在努力，这点我愿意给予我们肯定，以反映真实的经历。观众没有因此拒绝我们。事实上，我们越能做到这一点，观众就越让我们受欢迎。
But there were people in the beginning who said, "Oh, keep them out of the operating room. Nobody wants to see blood. That'll turn them off on the humor." If we had started a couple of years later, there would have been people who said, "Look, you've got all those nurses. Let's show the nurses in shorts and halters. And let's show them in their underwear and get them into wet t-shirts as much as you can," and stuff like that. Well, we pretty much didn't do that.
但一开始有人说：“噢，别让他们进手术室。没人想看血。那会破坏幽默感。”如果我们晚几年开始，就会有人说：“看，你有那么多护士。让我们展示那些穿着短裤和挂脖背心的护士。让他们尽可能地穿着内衣，穿着湿T恤，”之类的东西。嗯，我们基本没那样做。
Now, this seems like a stupid thing to say. But the fact is, a lot of people in the entertainment business are afraid that if you get too real, if you reflect experience too truly, that you'll scare people away, that they'll be bored, that it's not flashy enough, or it's not, in quotes, "entertaining" enough.
现在，这看起来像是个愚蠢的说法。但事实是，娱乐界有很多人害怕，如果你太真实，如果你太真实地反映经验，你会把人吓跑，他们会感到无聊，这不够浮夸，或者它不够，引号里的，“娱乐性”。
20 years ago, I listened to these tapes over and over for months, cutting and re-cutting the interviews late into the night, trying to turn them into a radio story. I remember staying at NPR's headquarters, camped out in an edit booth, long after everybody had left, day after day after day. I didn't know what I was doing. I never finished the story.
20年前，我一遍又一遍地听这些录音带，一连几个月，深夜里反复剪辑这些采访，试图把它们变成广播故事。我记得待在NPR总部，蹲在一个剪辑室里，在那之后很久大家都走了，日复一日。我不知道我在干什么。我从没完成那个故事。
Ashamed of myself, I packed the tapes away in a little box and pushed my feelings about the whole thing into another, different sort of little box, and then did what anybody does to move on. I tried to pretend that it never, ever happened. When I dream about M*A*S*H, the cast is polite, but it's clear that I did let them down.
因为自责，我把磁带装进了一个小盒子里，把我对整件事的感觉推进了另一个不同的、小盒子里，然后做了任何人都会做的事情来向前看。我试着假装那件事从来没发生过。当我梦到《M*A*S*H》时，演员们很有礼貌，但很明显我确实让他们失望了。
The problem with having a big, cringey moment on the set of one of the most successful series in the history of television is that the show doesn't really go away. I checked TV guide. And where I live, in Chicago, M*A*S*H is on 10 times a day.
在电视史上最成功系列之一的片场有一次尴尬时刻的问题在于，节目并没有真正消失。我查了电视指南。在我住的地方，芝加哥，《M*A*S*H》每天播放10次。
It was my Grandma Molly's very favorite show. And for years after I visited the set of M*A*S*H, if she and I were ever together at any kind of setting, like a party or a wedding, or any setting with lots of people around, she would tell everybody at some point, in a big voice, how I had gone to the set of M*A*S*H, and wasn't that incredible? And then everybody would gather around. And people would get all excited. And they would start kvelling.
这是我奶奶莫莉最喜欢的节目。在我参观《M*A*S*H》片场后的几年里，如果她和我曾在任何场合在一起，比如聚会或婚礼，或者是任何有很多人的场合，她会在某个时候大声告诉每个人，我是如何去了《M*A*S*H》的片场，那难道不令人难以置信吗？然后每个人都会围过来。人们会变得非常兴奋。他们会开始赞美。
And they would start to ask me, "Well, so what was it like? What was it like?" And it was always hard to know what to do. And so there would always be this long moment where I summoned up the energy to say something. "They're all really nice," I'd say. "They're really, really nice."
他们会开始问我，“那么，那是什么样子的？那是什么感觉？”总是很难知道该做什么。于是总会有长长的一刻，我鼓起勇气说点什么。“他们真的很友善，”我会说，“他们真的、真的很好。”
Coming up, when the person who makes you cringe might be cringing at you. And can you undo a cringe? Our non-scientific inquiry continues, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，当那个让你尴尬的人可能正在为你感到尴尬时。你能撤销一个尴尬吗？我们的非科学调查将继续进行，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, stories that make us cringe, and some thoughts about what it is about these stories that makes us have this physical reaction. We have arrived at act three of our program. Act Three, Ariel Sharon, Shimon Peres, David Ben-Gurion, and Me.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，那些让我们感到尴尬的故事，以及关于是什么让这些故事引发我们生理反应的一些想法。我们已经到达节目的第三幕。第三幕，阿里埃勒·沙龙、西蒙·佩雷斯、戴维·本-古里安和我。
"December 3, 1986, Wednesday. Another fascinating day in the life of Adam Davidson. I have a math test tomorrow. I'm going to school early to tutor a girl in my class for the aforementioned test.
“1986年12月3日，星期三。亚当·戴维森生活中的又一个迷人日子。明天我有个数学考试。我要早点去学校，为前述考试辅导班里的一位女生。
My math class, a joint precalculus and calculus class, consists mainly of seniors not especially interested in learning. I guess that I'm the quote, 'class expert,' unquote, in that I always do the math problems which no one else can. And for this, I'm disliked. I guess that because I apply myself, think clearly, and do a little work, as well as some intelligence helping out, I am a geek. In truth, I am far from it."
我的数学课，一门微积分预备课和微积分合上的课，主要由对学习不太感兴趣的高年级学生组成。我想我是所谓的“班级专家”，因为我总是能做别人做不出来的数学题。因此，我不受待见。我想因为我努力、思考清晰、做点工作，再加上一点智力辅助，我是个书呆子。事实上，我远非如此。”
When you first read that to yourself, when you first saw it, your reaction was?
当你第一次向自己读到这段，当你第一次看到它时，你的反应是？
It was pure horror.
纯粹的惊恐。
Recently, Adam Davidson, an occasional contributor to our program, found his old high school diaries. Adam's mom is Israeli. His dad is American. Adam grew up in New York. Well, his body was in New York. His brain, as the diaries reveal, was somewhere else entirely.
最近，我们节目的特约撰稿人亚当·戴维森发现了他的旧高中日记。亚当的妈妈是以色列人。他父亲是美国人。亚当在纽约长大。嗯，他的身体在纽约。正如日记所揭示的，他的大脑完全在别处。
I remember when I was writing it, I remember very clearly, although I don't say this in the diary, that it was very clear to me that this was the diary of the future Prime Minister of Israel, me. That I would one day be prime minister. And it would be very important for history for people to know the deep thoughts of a young Zionist as he prepared his way to lead his nation.
我记得写它时，我记得非常清楚，尽管我在日记中没这么说，我非常清楚这是未来以色列总理——我——的日记。有一天我会成为总理。让人们了解一位年轻的犹太复国主义者在为领导国家做好准备时的深层思想，这对历史将非常重要。
Now, our regular listeners here on This American Life might remember that you've been on our program describing your experience in Israeli Army summer camp.
现在，我们《美国生活》的常听众可能记得你曾在我们节目中描述你在以色列军队夏令营的经历。
That was right before I started writing this dairy.
那就在我开始写这本该死的东西之前。
Read me another.
再读一段。
Sure. Let's see. "There's so much wrong with Jews in Israel that I'm going to have a job ahead of me. One thing is the lack of any strong Jewish identity among most Jews. This attitude sickens me.
当然。让我看看。“以色列犹太人有很多问题，我以后有的忙了。其中之一是大多数犹太人缺乏强烈的犹太认同感。这种态度让我恶心。
You Jews of the world, stop worrying about money and well-being. I do not know what exactly I'll do. But if this situation continues when I'm a bit older, then watch out, world Jewry, here comes Adam." And "watch out world Jewry, here comes Adam" was all in capital letters.
你们世界各地的犹太人，别再担心金钱和安逸了。我不知道我具体会做什么。但如果这种情况持续到我长大一点，那么小心了，世界犹太人，亚当来了。”而且，“小心了，世界犹太人，亚当来了”全是用了大写字母。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
是啊。
It's interesting that you actually are addressing a readership.
有趣的是你实际上是在对着读者写作。
I know. I know. That's what's kind of amazing.
我知道。我知道。这很惊人。
And that leadership is world Jewry.
而那个受众是世界犹太人。
Yeah I have this thing from January 4, 1987. "I memorized "The Hope," "Hatikva," which is the Israeli national anthem, a few minutes ago. That will help me in Israel."
是啊，我从1987年1月4日有这一条。“我几分钟前背下了《希望》，即《Hatikva》，是以色列国歌。那会在以色列帮到我。”
I find that really amazing, that here I am, the future Prime Minister of Israel, and what are the things I need? Oh god, I need to know the national anthem. I'll probably be called upon to recite that at some point.
我发现这真的很神奇，这里我，未来的以色列总理，而我需要的东西是什么？噢，天哪，我需要知道国歌。我可能会在某个时候被要求朗诵它。
At 16, I had such an inflated sense of myself. There was so much going on in my life then that I can remember. And I wasn't recording it.
16岁时，我对自己有种膨胀感。那时我生活中发生了那么多我可以记得的事情。但我没记录下来。
Instead, I was creating this ridiculous fantasy of, I'm not just a 16-year-old kid who's having crushes, and a hopeless geek who can't get a girl to kiss him, and being scared and confused about growing old. I'm the future Prime Minister of Israel. And everything goes through that. But I don't know.
相反，我创造了这个荒谬的幻想：我不是一个只会暗恋、一个无法让女孩亲吻自己的无助书呆子、一个害怕且困惑于衰老的16岁小孩。我是未来的以色列总理。一切都通过那个视角看待。但我不知道。
But maybe keeping a diary where one tells the truth, maybe that's a luxury of being a certain kind of person in a certain kind of situation. Maybe other people in another kind of situation need to actually make up a little fantasy.
但也许写日记讲述真相是一种身为某类人在某种情况下的奢侈。也许处于另一种情况下的其他人真的需要编造一点幻想。
Yeah, I think I didn't have much angst about being the future Prime Minister of Israel. I was very calm and confident and comfortable with it. And I had so much angst about every other aspect of my life. And so I now see it as just kind of a-- maybe it was a good solution. It was a good way to deal with what I was going through, to have this space where I could just be one of the greats.
是啊，我想我对成为未来的以色列总理没多少焦虑。我对此非常平静、自信和自在。我对自己生活中其他每一个方面都有太多的焦虑。所以我现在觉得这只是一种——也许这是个好的解决方案。这是一种处理我所经历的事情的好方法，拥有这个我可以成为伟大人物之一的空间。
I wonder what the 16-year-old Adam Davidson would feel knowing that finally, an audience of a million people was getting some of the reading from this diary.
我想知道16岁的亚当·戴维森知道终于有一百万听众在阅读这本日记时会有什么感觉。
I think this would feel so small to that 16-year-old. This would feel so nothing. This would be so unimportant.
我想这对那个16岁的人来说感觉太渺小了。这会感觉毫无意义。这会非常不重要。
Being on the radio.
上广播。
Being on the radio, a million people, what's a million people? I mean, we're talking about history. We're talking about sweeping changes. I'm pretty sure that he would be thoroughly unimpressed.
上广播，一百万人，一百万人算什么？我的意思是，我们在谈论历史。我们在谈论彻底的变革。我很确定他会彻底不为所动。
And Adam, what would the 16-year-old you think of you now?
那么亚当，16岁的你会怎么看现在的你？
I think he'd be really disappointed. I think he'd be really sad.
我想他会非常失望。我想他会非常难过。
Because you're not the Prime Minister of Israel?
因为你不是以色列总理？
Yeah, because I just have such a small life. I remember I was very disappointed and very sad about my parents. I was reading biographies, of course, of all the Prime Ministers of Israel.
是啊，因为我的人生如此渺小。我记得我对我父母感到非常失望和悲伤。我当时当然在读所有以色列总理的传记。
And I would just think about my parents, and just think, how do you wake up every day knowing that your actions won't affect millions of people? How is that enough motivation, just to have your petty little craft, and your petty little family, and your small, little apartment? It just seemed pathetic. And they have the kind of life that basically, I want for myself.
我只会想到我的父母，只会想，你们怎么能每天醒来时知道自己的行为不会影响数百万人？怎么那就能成为足够的动力，仅仅拥有你们那些卑微的小手艺、你们卑微的小家庭和你们渺小的小公寓？这看起来简直可悲。而他们拥有那种我基本上想为自己拥有的生活。
What you're saying, though, is that the 16-year-old you would be cringing at your 30-year-old version, just as your 30-year-old version is cringing at the 16.
不过你所说的是，16岁的你会在审视30岁的你时感到尴尬，就像30岁的你在审视16岁的你时感到尴尬一样。
Yeah, that's very true, yeah. He would be very, very disgusted if he heard this radio piece. It would seem like I had settled in a pathetic way.
是啊，那非常正确，是啊。如果他听到这期广播节目，他会非常、非常恶心。这看起来就像我以一种可悲的方式安顿下来了。
Act Four, Cringe and Purge. There are a lot of stories in your life that the more you tell them, the less power they have over you. It's like they wear themselves out like chewing gum that stops having flavor. But cringe stories somehow do not seem to lose their power over time. Every time you remember, you cringe. So what do you do if you want to stop cringing? We have this story from Bruce Jay Friedman about somebody who decides to take action.
第四幕：尴尬与净化。你生活中有很多故事，讲述得越多，它们对你的控制力就越弱。它们就像嚼久了失去味道的口香糖一样耗尽了能量。但尴尬的故事似乎不会随着时间推移失去威力。每次你想起，你都会感到尴尬。所以如果你想停止尴尬，该怎么办？我们有这篇来自布鲁斯·杰伊·弗里德曼的故事，讲述了一个决定采取行动的人。
It had been a mild financial strain to take his wife and travel to Europe. And so for the first week, Gribitz kept reminding them that they were in a special place, much better than Rockaway Beach or Cape Cod. "You're drinking French water," he would tell his son each time the boy took a glassful. And on the way to the seashore, he would lean back and say to his wife, "Fill your lungs with some of that French air."
带着妻子去欧洲旅行造成了一点经济紧张。因此第一周，格里比茨不断提醒他们，他们身处一个特别的地方，比洛克威海滩或科德角好得多。“你在喝法国的水，”每当男孩喝下一杯水，他就告诉儿子。在去海边的路上，他会靠回座椅上对妻子说，“用那法国的空气填满你的肺。”
As for Gribitz, he tried to fill himself with enjoyment, to look everywhere at once and afraid that by doing so, he was seeing nothing. Besides, he could not feel entirely comfortable, because he had not seen a soul he knew. He tried to turn this into an advantage, telling his wife, "Isn't it great that we don't know a soul here, that we can just be by ourselves for a change?"
至于格里比茨，他试图让自己充满享受，四处张望，又担心这样看反而什么都没看到。此外，他没法感到彻底舒适，因为他没见到一个熟人。他试图把这变成一个优势，告诉妻子：“我们在这儿谁也不认识，这难道不是件好事吗？我们可以难得地只剩我们自己。”
But actually, he longed to see just one familiar face-- Henry Nester, his insurance man, or even Uncle Hicky, who traveled to exotic places each year and raved about Miami hotels. It wasn't so much that he was lonely, but that he wanted his sense of reality straightened. How else could he be sure he was in Europe, and that it was he, Gribitz, and not some fellow in a dream?
但实际上，他渴望见到一张熟悉的面孔——亨利·内斯特，他的保险代理人，甚至每年去异国旅行、对迈阿密酒店赞不绝口的希基叔叔。不是因为他感到孤独，而是他想理顺自己的现实感。不然他怎么能确定他真的在欧洲，是他，格里比茨，而不是梦里的某个家伙？
Each night, Gribitz and his wife would take seats at a sidewalk cafe and stare across the street at people in another sidewalk cafe. One night, he picked out a familiar face across the road said to his wife, "Uh-oh. I see one I think I know, only I hope I don't, because if it's him, it's going to start a whole thing." He excused himself and crossed the street.
每天晚上，格里比茨和妻子都会坐在街边咖啡馆，盯着马路对面另一家咖啡馆里的人。一天晚上，他挑出一个熟悉的面孔，对妻子说：“呃噢。我看到一个我想认识的人，但我希望不是他，因为如果那是他，整件事又要开始了。”他打了个招呼，穿过马路。
The fellow he went up to was well-muscled and had a deep-seamed suntan but also great swoops of hair that might have more appropriate for a concert musician. Beside him sat a petulant wife and two girls in their early teens. "I'll be brief," said Gribitz. "Your name doesn't happen to be Carroll, does it? And were you once in the Air Force?" The fellow nodded. And Gribitz said, "I'll be going back now. I just wanted to nail this down out of curiosity."
他走近的那个人肌肉发达，晒成了深色，但长着像音乐会演奏家那样夸张的头发。他旁边坐着个娇气的妻子和两个十几岁的女儿。“长话短说，”格里比茨说，“你姓卡罗尔吧？你曾经在空军服役过吗？”那家伙点了点头。格里比茨说：“我得回去了。我出于好奇只是想确认一下。”
Gribitz returned to his table and said, "Well, it's him all right. It's amazing what a whole cascade of things just came tumbling into my head. Well, I've finally seen someone, and I know it's me, right here in Europe now. Only I wish that fellow had been one of at least 4,000 other people I could mention."
格里比茨回到餐桌说：“嗯，没错，就是他。真不可思议，一连串的事情瞬间涌进我的脑子里。好了，我终于见到某个人了，我知道这就是我，此时此刻就在欧洲。只是我真希望那家伙是我能提到的其他至少4000人里的一个。”
On the way back to their villa, Gribitz said, "Look. I'm not trying to be mysterious. It's the kind of story I just have to slide into, you know, when I get comfortable. I'm not even sure how important it is right now."
在回别墅的路上，格里比茨说：“看。我不是在装神弄鬼。这只是那种故事，你知道，等我舒服点了自然会讲。我甚至不确定它现在有多重要。”
But he couldn't sleep that night. He got up, woke his wife and said, "Look, I've always been honest. What's really getting to me is that fellow I just told you about, the one I'd rather not have run into. I thought I'd just think it out and pass it by, but it's not working out that way. I'm just being honest." "Don't be so honest," said his wife.
但他那天晚上睡不着。他起来，叫醒妻子说：“听着，我一直很诚实。真正困扰我的是我刚跟你讲的那个家伙，那个我本不想碰到的。我以为我会思考一下就过去了，但并不是这样。我只是在说实话。”“别那么诚实了，”他妻子说。
The next morning, Gribitz called American Express. And then, in the middle of breakfast, he suddenly shoved aside a croissant and said, "Look, I don't really love these. I don't see why I have to go through the motions.
第二天早上，格里比茨给美国运通打了电话。然后，在早餐中间，他突然推开羊角面包说：“听着，我其实并不喜欢这些。我不明白为什么我非得走过场。
"All right. Now here's the deal. I'm going after that fellow. Let me rephrase that. I'm going to visit that sunburned guy from the cafe last night. What happened is a long time ago, maybe 15 years now, he humiliated me in front of 250 guys. Don't ask me how he did it. I was a new officer. He was an enlisted man. It shouldn't have happened that way, but it did.
“好了。现在听好了。我要去找那个家伙。让我换种说法。我要去拜访昨晚咖啡馆里那个晒得黝黑的家伙。那是很久以前的事了，大概15年前，他在250个人面前羞辱了我。别问我他怎么做的。我当时是个新军官。他是名入伍士兵。事情本不该那样发生，但确实发生了。
I thought I'd forgotten all about it. I don't think I've thought of it once in the last eight years. But I guess it was simmering right there under the surface all along. Now I've tracked him down to Golfe Sainte-Juan. He's out of the service now with some engineering outfit. Anyway, I'm off to check in on him now. And don't even think about talking me out of it.
我以为我已经彻底忘记了。我想过去八年我一次都没想过。但我想它一直都在表象下闷烧着。现在我在圣瑞昂湾追踪到了他。他现在退役了，在一家工程公司工作。总之，我现在要去见他。别想劝我放弃。
But there is one thing I've got ask you to do. There's no effort involved. Just call me at this number in exactly an hour and a half. You know, I'm not really asking. This is one of those few marriage times when I've got to tell you, 'Just make the call, or that's it for us.'"
但我得请你做一件事。不需要费力。正好一个半小时后打这个号码给我。你知道，我不是在请求你。这是为数不多的几个婚姻时刻之一，我必须告诉你，‘一定要打那个电话，否则我们就完了。’”
"All right," she said, "but was there really a need to frame it exactly that way?" "There was a need. There was a need. Trust me," said Gribitz. "I have no time to go into any psychology with you. Just start twirling that dial in une heure et demie."
“好吧，”她说，“但真的有必要那样说吗？”“有必要。有必要。相信我，”格里比茨说，“我没时间跟你谈心理学。就在一个半小时后拨那个号码吧。”
Gribitz drove for half an hour, checked his watch, and then stopped off at a roadside cafe to get 12 cooked snails to go. He was the only customer, and two restaurant troubadours asked if they could play and sing for him. "Look, I'm not in that kind of mood," he said. But he finally allowed them to do "Quando, Quando, Quando," a slow cha-cha popular in the States.
格里比茨开了半小时车，看了看手表，然后在路边咖啡馆停下买了12只熟蜗牛带走。他是唯一的顾客，两位餐厅游吟诗人问能不能为他演奏唱歌。“听着，我没那个心情，”他说。但他最终还是允许他们演奏了《Quando, Quando, Quando》，那是在美国很流行的慢节奏恰恰舞曲。
As they sang to him, he thought about the Air Force and the thing Carroll had done to him. Very simply, what happened was that Gribitz, on his second day as an officer in the Air Force, fresh from college, had been tossed into the thick of an experienced combat Air Force squadron of 250 men. One day, the entire squadron had been assembled for a weapons talk. Gribitz sat at the back of the auditorium, knowing nothing, scared out of his wits that momentarily he'd be unmasked as an idiot.
当他们为他演唱时，他想到了空军和卡罗尔对他做的那件事。非常简单，事情是这样的：格里比茨，作为空军军官的第二天，刚从大学出来，就被扔进了250名经验丰富的作战空军中队的中间。一天，整个中队集合进行武器讲座。格里比茨坐在礼堂后排，什么都不懂，吓坏了，怕随时会被揭穿是个白痴。
In the middle of the lecture, the phone rang, loud and clear, the speaker waiting for it to be answered. Gribitz, a few feet away from the phone, could think of no way in the world in which he could have assisted the caller, since there was nothing in the world he knew about the Air Force. So while the audience waited, he asked Carroll, who was then a master sergeant, to answer the phone. Carroll, after thinking it over for a second, said "No," with a queer little smile.
讲座中间，电话响了，声音响亮而清晰，演讲者等着人去接。格里比茨离电话几英尺远，想不到有什么理由他能帮上忙，因为他对空军一窍不通。所以当听众等着时，他请卡罗尔——当时的军士长——接电话。卡罗尔想了一秒钟后，带着那种古怪的微笑说“不”。
Gribitz sat up then. And with all 250 men looking on, he asked Carroll a second time to pick up the phone. "I said no," Carroll replied. And Gribitz, his collar suddenly strangling him, had run out of the auditorium on the fourth or fifth ring.
格里比茨当时坐直了。在所有250人注视下，他第二次请卡罗尔接电话。“我说不，”卡罗尔回答。格里比茨，衣领突然让他窒息，在第四或第五声响铃时跑出了礼堂。
The proper procedure, of course, would have been to bring court martial charges against Carroll for disobeying a direct order. And Gribitz, however untutored he'd been at the time, at least knew this much. But he had been just as frightened of his immediate superior and a court martial procedure, as he was of master sergeants and telephones. Doing anything then had been out of the question.
当然，正确的程序应该是以违抗直接命令为由对卡罗尔提起军事法庭指控。格里比茨，尽管当时没受过训练，至少也知道这么多。但他同样害怕他的直属上司和军事法庭程序，正如他害怕军士长和电话一样。当时做任何事都是不可能的。
Thinking about the incident now, he got a little hitch to his breath. It had stuck in his throat. And in many ways, it spoiled his entire service experience, just as meeting Carroll the previous night now threatened to upset him for weeks to come.
现在想起来，他呼吸有点急促。那事卡在他喉咙里。在许多方面，它破坏了他整个服役经历，正如昨晚遇到卡罗尔现在威胁要让他烦恼数周一样。
The troubadours ended their number. The snails arrived. And the check had an extra 20% added on for entertainment. "I just wish I had time to argue," he said as he paid the cashier. "I'd take you right down to the wire on that entertainment crap. I didn't ask for it. It wasn't entertaining."
游吟诗人结束了表演。蜗牛到了，账单上额外加了20%的娱乐费。“我真希望我有时间争论，”他付钱给收银员时说。“我会在这笔垃圾娱乐费上跟你死磕到底。我没要求。它根本不娱乐。”
He drove another 20 minutes or so. And after some muddling about in a cliffside community overhanging the waterfront, he found a house with the name Carroll out front. Mrs. Carroll answered the doorbell. And Gribitz said, "Hi, I'm Leroy Gribitz, and I'm here to do some business with your husband. And I brought you some cooked snails. They make them all over the country, I know that. But I think you'll find these have a little extra zip to them. I mean, that's been my experience. And you know, give some to the kids. Is your husband home?"
他又开了大概20分钟车。在俯瞰海滨的悬崖社区里兜兜转转一番后，他找到了一个门口写着卡罗尔名字的房子。卡罗尔夫人开了门。格里比茨说：“嗨，我是勒罗伊·格里比茨，我来找你丈夫办点事。我带了些熟蜗牛给你。我知道全国各地都有做的。但我认为你会发现这几只有点特别的味道。我是说，根据我的经验。你知道，给孩子吃点。你丈夫在家吗？”
The woman called inside, then disappeared. And when the deep-seamed man came out, Gribitz said, "How are you doing, Carroll. I'm the guy who approached you last night at the cafe. And to get right down to it, I'm A02234907, Grange Air Force Base, 1951 to 1953, the young kid adjutant of squadron 4507 who you did that thing to."
那女人往里喊了一声，然后消失了。当那个皮肤黝黑的男人出来时，格里比茨说：“你好啊，卡罗尔。我是昨晚在咖啡馆接近你的那个人。直接说吧，我是A02234907，格兰奇空军基地，1951年到1953年，4507中队那个被你整过的年轻中尉。”
Carroll, who was wearing rimless Ben Franklin glasses coming into vogue on the Cote D'Azur, took them off his nose, stroked his chin, and said, "You know, I think I do remember. Young kid comes into the squadron, never done a lick of military and comes in as an officer yet." "The very kid," said Gribitz. "And while you're unwinding the spool, see if you can remember the little business you pulled on me that I'm here for now, 15 years later, about the telephone."
卡罗尔戴着在蔚蓝海岸正流行的无框本·富兰克林眼镜，他摘下眼镜，摸了摸下巴，说：“你知道，我想我记得。有个新来的小孩进了中队，从来没干过一天军活，还以军官身份入伍。”“就是那小孩，”格里比茨说，“在你理顺思路的时候，看看能不能想起你在电话上对我干的那件我15年后专门为此而来的小把戏。”
"I do remember that thing," said Carroll, taking a seat at a dinette arrangement. "You mean when the phone rings, and it's clearly the duty of the officer in charge to pick it up, and you expected me, a master sergeant with 12 years duty on you, to do your dirty work for you, and I wouldn't?"
“我记得那件事，”卡罗尔在餐桌旁坐下说。“你是说电话响的时候，接听明显是负责军官的职责，而你却指望我，一个比你资历老12年的军士长，去做你的脏活，而我不干？”
"That's the time, all right. You disgraced me, pure and simple, in front of 250 guys I could never look in the face again. You fouled up my whole time in the service. I don't think I got one good night of Air Force sleep. And don't think I didn't think about it plenty after my discharge. The thing is, it's 15 years later. We're both here in this house. And we're playing that little scene again, only with a different ending.
“就是那次。你让我丢尽了脸，赤裸裸的，在250个我再也没脸面对的家伙面前。你搞砸了我整个服役期。我想我没过过一个安稳的空军之夜。别以为我退伍后没想过这事。问题是，那是15年后了。我们都在这个房子里。我们要重演那个小场景，只是结局不同。
In 20 minutes to the second, that phone is going to ring. And when it does, you're going to be the one to answer it." "I always answer the phone when it rings," said Carroll, beginning to pick his teeth. "Look, now don't be any wise bastard," said Gribitz, "or you'll be hearing an entirely different kind of ring. You know damn well what I mean.
20分钟后，那电话会响。到时候，你必须是接听的那一个。”“我接电话时总是接的，”卡罗尔开始剔牙，“听着，别耍滑头，”格里比茨说，“否则你会听到完全不同种类的响铃。你很清楚我在说什么。
I've got that phone set up to ring in 20 minutes. It's no ordinary phone call. It's the same one from the squadron 15 years ago. We both hear it, and you're the one that makes a grab for it, not me this time.
我把电话设定在20分钟后响。这不是普通的电话。那是15年前中队的同一个电话。我们都听着，这次该你抢着去接了，不再是我。”
And before you make any smart-ass comments, let me tell you why you're going to pick it up and not me. I mean, I may look the same as I did 15 years ago-- the same general body outline and all. But actually, I'm like four of what I was. I've been working out like a madman. The point is, I can get things done now, just about anything, anything I want, if I concentrate hard enough. How do you think I pulled off this trip? I set my sails for it and bulled it through with sheer willpower."
“在你发表任何俏皮话之前，让我告诉你为什么你得去接它而不是我。我是说，我看起来可能和15年前一样——大致的身体轮廓等等。但实际上，我是原来的四倍。我一直在像疯子一样锻炼。重点是，我现在能搞定事情，任何事情，我想做的任何事，只要我集中精力。你以为我是怎么搞定这趟旅行的？我扬帆起航，靠着纯粹的意志力把它顶了过来。”
"All right," said Carroll. "When does it ring?" "I told you when," said Gribitz. "When I said is when. You never should have done that thing to me."
“好吧，”卡罗尔说，“它什么时候响？”“我告诉过你什么时候，”格里比茨说，“我说什么时候就是什么时候。你永远不该那样对待我。”
The phone rang, and Carroll, after flicking at some rear molars, picked up the phone casually and said, "Carroll speaking. Who's this?" He listened for a while and then said, "OK, make it chopped steak instead of cotelette d'agneau." "That was the butcher," said Carroll, laying down the receiver. "All right, forget that," said Gribitz, checking his watch. "Our call has another five minutes to go."
电话响了，卡罗尔在剔了会儿后槽牙后，随意地拿起电话说：“我是卡罗尔。谁啊？”他听了一会儿说，“好的，那就把小排换成猪排。”“那是屠夫，”卡罗尔放下听筒说。“好了，别管那个了，”格里比茨看着手表说，“我们的通话还有五分钟。”
"Look," said Carroll. "Why don't I just go beep, beep beep, pick it up, OK? We've got the show packed up, and we get out of here." "Well, that'll be the day," said Gribitz. "I'll bet you'd just love to pull something like that on me."
“听着，”卡罗尔说，“为什么我不干脆‘嘟、嘟、嘟’接起来就行了呢？我们要打包走人，得离开这儿了。”“那才怪，”格里比茨说，“我敢打赌你肯定很想对我搞这一套。”
They sat together in silence, and after two minutes, the phone rang again. "Carroll here, answering the phone as ordered," he said. He held the receiver aside and said to Gribitz, "Now you want me to just gab for a while?" "No," said Gribitz. "Just what you did does it." "Signing off," said Carroll, and laid down the receiver.
他们沉默地坐在一起，两分钟后，电话又响了。 “卡罗尔在这，按命令接电话，”他说。他把听筒搁一边对格里比茨说，“现在你想让我随便扯一会儿吗？”“不，”格里比茨说，“这就够了。”“挂了，”卡罗尔说，放下听筒。
Gribitz, who hadn't realized how hard he'd been breathing, pulled out a handkerchief and pulled it across his brow. "Well, that's done," he said. "And what's done is done." "Yup," said Carroll. "You been here long?" asked Gribitz. "Ah, a year," said Carroll. "Do your kids have anyone to play with?" "They do alright," said Carroll. "Well, maybe they could come over and play with mine. Boy, wouldn't that be a hell of a turn?
格里比茨没意识到自己一直呼吸得这么急促，掏出手帕擦了擦额头。“好了，搞定了，”他说，“过去就让它过去吧。”“是的，”卡罗尔说。“你来这儿很久了吗？”格里比茨问。“啊，一年，”卡罗尔说。“你孩子有玩伴吗？”“他们还行，”卡罗尔说，“嗯，也许他们可以过来跟我孩子一起玩。天哪，那难道不是个巨大的反转吗？
Look, all of this was just something I had to get out of my system. I know a little bit about myself. If I have something like that bothering me, it can throw off my entire life. It's just like a splinter. You know the kind of grief that can give you? I mean, am I getting through to you at all?" "I guess," said Carroll, waiting with his hand on the door.
听着，所有这些只是我必须从系统中排出的东西。我知道一点关于自己的事。如果我有这种困扰我的事，它会搞砸我整个人生。它就像一根刺。你知道那能带给你多大的痛苦吗？我是说，你有听懂我一点吗？”“我想吧，”卡罗尔说着，手搭在门上等待着。
"Look, when I saw you, I knew I wasn't going to be able to relax until I'd come over here and gotten the damn thing done. I mean, now that it's done, to me, it's as if nothing happened. What I'm getting at is it was nothing personal. I mean, do you see that at all?"
“听着，当我见到你时，我知道如果不过来把这该死的事搞定，我没法放松。我是说，现在搞定了，对我来说，就像什么都没发生过。我想表达的是，这没什么个人恩怨。我是说，你明白这一点吗？”
"I don't see much of anything," said Carroll, opening the door for Gribitz to leave. "All right. I'm going to get you for this," said Gribitz, taking his coat, "for what you're doing right now. I don't care if it takes another 15 years. I mean, you can hide in the goddamned mountains of Tibet. I'll smoke you out, and I'll beat your head 'til you're bloody, because you have gone and spoiled my whole European vacation, you son of a bitch."
“我不觉得有什么大不了，”卡罗尔说着，打开门让格里比茨离开。“好吧。我会找你算账的，”格里比茨拿起外套说，“为了你现在做的这些事。我不在乎是否还要再过15年。我是说，你可以躲到该死的西藏山里去。我会把你揪出来，把你脑袋敲到头破血流，因为你搞砸了我整个欧洲假期，你这个混蛋。”
Bruce Jay Friedman's story, "The Humiliation," can be found in a book that is called, simply enough, The Collected Short Fiction of Bruce Jay Friedman. He has a new book coming out in September called Sexual Pensees.
布鲁斯·杰伊·弗里德曼的故事《羞辱》收录在名为《布鲁斯·杰伊·弗里德曼短篇小说集》的书里。他九月有一本新书要出版，叫《性沉思》。
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Goldstein and myself with Alex Blumberg, Blue Chevigny, and Starlee Kine. Our senior producer, Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Annie Baxter, Seth Lind and Sativa January. Musical help from Terry Hecker.
好的，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·戈德斯坦和我本人与亚历克斯·布伦伯格、蓝色·谢维尼和斯塔利·基恩制作。我们的高级制作人，朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特运营我们的网站。制作援助来自托德·巴赫曼和安妮·巴克斯特，塞思·林德和萨蒂瓦·詹纽瑞。音乐帮助来自特里·赫克。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Nancy Updike's story was produced partly with funds from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting as part of hearingvoices.com. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free or buy CDs of them. You know, you can download today's program at our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
南希·厄普代克的报道部分资金来自公共广播公司，作为hearingvoices.com项目的一部分。我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目或购买CD。你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia, who I just ran into in the hallway. It was weird. He said--
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督是托里·马拉蒂亚先生，我刚才在走廊碰到他。真奇怪。他说——
Oh, no. I can't believe you're here today.
噢，不。真不敢相信你今天在这儿。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。